you must do the same and reveal your
true self
I am Ava rain
Dwayne Johnson's daughter Simone AKA Ava
Rayne has officially entered the ring
the best piece of advice that my dad
gave me was just to have fun and live in
the moment the 21 year old who
officially started her career in the WWE
in 2020 made her debut Tuesday night in
her first televised appearance on NXT
her name Ava Rayne the fourth member of
wrestler Joe Gacy's faction Schism the
love and acceptance the Schism has given
me defies any preconceived notions of
who I'm supposed to be
this family
completes me
[Applause]
Simone's of course carrying the family's
Legacy following in the footsteps of her
great-grandfather Peter Maivia
grandfather Rocky Johnson and her dad
Dwayne Johnson or as you may know him
The Rock
[Music]
a Rock is cooking
you could definitely count on over the
edge you can count on attitude you can
count on the Rock being the best damn
WWF Champion ever was and for Simone her
family history is a big reason why she's
now a part of it obviously wrestling is
cool I admired and I love it but to know
that my family has such a personal
connection in it it's really special to
me and I feel really grateful to just be
able to have this opportunity to not
only wrestle but to also carry on that
Legacy thank you a proud papa because
she's carrying on the Legacy fourth
generation she's making him history
she's made history very very proud of
her she is fiercely independent it's
very important for her to make her own
way Blaze her own trail Blaze her own
path uh so she doesn't come to me uh
looking for a lot which I respect that
and I'm here watching and supporting the
rock retired from the WWE in 2004 but
made a brief return in 2011. after seven
long years
finally
The Rock has come back to Monday Night
Raw
you know in the world of pro wrestling
it's it's a there's nothing like the
world of pro wrestling it's very unique
and it's also a business professional
wrestling WWE it's in my blood it's my
passion I love it and someone who thinks
Dwayne should make another comeback
fellow former wrestler John Cena Dwayne
Johnson is a star in his own Universe
there's there's no one like him there
will never be anyone like him for him to
be gracious enough to return to WWE its
own Global entertainment phenomenon that
is great for WWE and I think it is great
for the rock I I can't speak for him I
don't want to speak for him as a fan of
WWE I really hope he returns I think it
would be special for everyone because he
wants to see DJ back in the ring could
it ever happen of course yeah I'm always
always open to that for sure
foreign